Друзі, усім привіт! Настав час третьої серії про сміття.
А пам'ятаєте, у першій «сміттєвій» серії я викидав пляшки?
У Німеччині скло сортують за кольором.
Відповідно, окремо викидають коричневі, зелені і прозорі пляшки.
Ну що ж, простежимо, що відбувається зі склом далі.
«Викидайте пляшки, будь ласка, лише в робочі дні з 7 до 20 години».
Така табличка - на кожному контейнері для скла.
Це правило має захистити жителів навколишніх будинків від гучного звуку скла, що б'ється.
Сьома ранку. Водій Андреас Фрітц вдягає на пояс
прилад дистанційного керування і починає свою робочу зміну.
Сьогодні він має зібрати контейнери зі склом в районні Бонна - Бад Годесберг.
Ті, хто ще не прокинувся, точно встануть після звуку падіння двох тонн пляшок.
У Бонні вивезенням скла займається компанія Ремондіс.
Пан Фрітц відточеними рухами піднімає краном-маніпулятором контейнер,
він зависає над вантажним відділенням для відповідного кольору, натиск кнопки і…
- Зараз контейнер відкриється, щоб випало скло.
Вантажне відділення поділене на три сектори –
відповідно для прозорих, зелених і коричневих пляшок.
Схоже, що Андреас вже із заплющеними очима
може повторювати цю операцію протягом 8-годинної робочої зміни.
- Скільки контейнерів спустошуєте за день?
- Зазвичай від 30 до 35 контейнерів.
Пан Фрітц на зміні один. Працює і як водій вантажівки, і як оператор крана-маніпулятора.
– Треба починати це робити повільно і обережно. З часом приходять навички швидкої роботи.
Згодом скло доставляють до станції сортування.
Тут його добивають на дрібніші друзки.
Далі електронно-оптична система визначає,
де є домішки іншого кольору, і повітря під тиском їх видуває.
Так само відділяють пластик, порцеляну, кераміку і каміння.
Камери здатні розрізняти 16 мільйонів відтінків кольорів.
Магніт витягає залізні кришки.
Друзки миють і виплавляють із них нові пляшки.
Це набагато дешевше, аніж виготовляти нове скло, наприклад, з кварцевого піску.
Адже температура плавлення старого скла починається від 300 градусів,
а температура варіння нового  - близько 1600 градусів,
тож це потребує набагато більших енергетичних витрат.
- Друзі, у ваших коментарях ви неодноразово просили показати,
як у Німеччині збирають листя.
На зміну виїжджає ось такий величезний «пилосос» і просто всмоктує його всередину.
«Рукавом» пилососа також керують дистанційно.
Ґергард Вінкель вирахував, що найоптимальніше збирати листя, якщо розкрутити «рукав» по колу.
Після дощу разом з листям пилосос затягує і воду з калюж.
- Дуже багато води всередині, через це турбіна не крутиться.
- О, пішла  вода назовні.
- Знову є тяга, супер!
А ось так я ледь не втратив iPhone компанії Deutsche Welle
Замінюємо батарею у пульті дистанційного керування і прибираємо листя далі.
– Ви подивіться яку штуковину мені доручили!
Ну що, спробуємо, як це працює.
Все дуже просто, однак треба не засмоктати квіти сусідів.
Це було дуже сильно.
- Добре, дякую! Працюйте далі. У вас краще виходить, ніж у мене.
T25 – найбільший з існуючих вакуумних контейнерів в лінійці компанії Trilo.
Сміттярі кажуть, він вміщує 7 тонн листя.
Вартість контейнера - 48 тисяч євро плюс 110 тисяч євро -
вантажівка Mercedes-Benz Actros.
Компанія BonnOrange, відповідальна за прибирання листя у Бонні,
має такі «пилососи» різних модифікацій і розмірів.
А коли на допомогу прийшла бригада з двома величезними щітками,
справа пішла швидше.
На сьогоднішньому маршруті все листя зібране.
Час їхати на компостну станцію.
За кермом - 28-річний Марсель Шнітцлер.
Він почав працювати в BonnOrange одразу після навчання на звичайного сміттяра.
Півроку тому здав на права водіння вантажівки і підвищив свою кваліфікацію.
Його зарплата зараз - близько двох тисяч євро після сплати всіх податків.
– У підсумку їздиш як на автівці, тільки більшого розміру. Мені подобається.
Їдемо у селище Вахтберг, що за 15 кілометрів від  Бонна.
Там розташована компостна станція.
Листя порізане і спресоване. Сьогодні на вулицях Бонна вдалося зібрати 5,5 тонн.
А ось так листя виглядатиме за 30 днів.
На етапі розкладання температура всередині компостної купи сягає 70 градусів.
- Сюди звозять усі зелені відходи з міста Бонн. Їх подрібнюють і переробляють.
Подрібнення відбувається за допомогою колісного навантажувача і подрібнювача.
Після подріблення сортувальний барабан розділяє крупну і дрібну фракції.
Спеціально під ці тріски у Німеччині виготовляють котли для опалення,
тож деревина піде туди.
А дрібна фракція насипається на купи для наступної фази копостування – гуміфікації.
– Тут компостуються обрізки саду, опале листя і деревина.
Ну що ж, традиційно - перевірка на запах.
Пахне сирістю і осінню.
На компостній станції простонеба відбувається звичайне природне диво:
рослинні відходи стають товаром.
Тисяча літрів такого гумусу для саду коштує 27 євро 50 центів.
Ще один вид сміття в Німеччині – покинуті велосипеди.
Подивимося, як німці вирішують це питання,
на прикладі велопарковки біля Deutsche Welle.
Серед десятків найрізноманітніших велосипедів привертають увагу ровери
з товстим шаром пилу і павутинням.
Видно, що вже понад рік на них сідали хіба що голуби.
На такі велосипеди комунальні служби Бонна вішають таблички:
"Дорогий власнику, за місяць ми зламаємо замок і заберемо цей велосипед".
Згодом ті велосипеди, на яких ще можна їздити, продають на аукціоні
у приміщенні міської ради. Решта йде на переробку.
Окремо переробляють метал, гуму і пластик.
У багатьох німецьких будинках є велосипедна кімната.
Тут зберігаються веліки всіх мешканців цього будинку.
Однак з часом виникає така ж проблема як і на велостоянках у місті.
І ті родини, які не хочуть, щоб їхні велосипеди викинули на смітник,
вішають на свою власність таблички із прізвищем.
Вийду з тьмяного велопідвалу на світло.
Ну що ж настав цей сумний час продажу героя
першої серії відеоблогу «Відкривай Німеччину».
11 тисяч 359 кілометрів
я накатав на «Геркулесі» за три роки.
Здавати його на переробку не піднімається рука.
Я придбав цей ровер за 35 євро на блошиному ринку Бонна
влітку 2015-го, як тільки приїхав до Німеччини.
У процесі експлуатації вклав у ремонти ще близько 200 євро.
В усіх сміттєпереробних компаніях Бонна мені казали,
що перед тим, як віддати річ в ресайклінґ,
треба спробувати дати їй друге життя.
Звичайно ж, велосипед треба підготувати до продажу.
В інтернеті на сайті Фломаркту - блошиного ринку міста Бонн -
обираю місце для продажу на мапі міського парку.
Сплачую 5 євро і роздруковую підтвердження бронювання торгового місця.
Суботнім ранком чіпляю до велосипеда дитячий причіп сина, з якого він виріс,
і його перший велосипед. Спробую це все продати.
- Маєте бічні колеса?
- А, додаткові бічні колеса, нажаль, я їх відкрутив уже,
бо мій син навчився кататися.
Однак вони були там, але я їх не взяв із собою.
- Дуже класний дзвінок.
Демонструю, як працюють гальма, і ми швидко домовляємося.
Дитячий велосипед марки «Геркулес» сподобався і батькам, і дитині.
- Ну це ж треба, не встиг ще розставити речі, а велосипед вже купили.
30 євро – нормальна ціна.
Нові власники ровера буксирують його додому,
а моя досвідчена сусідка по торговій точці бачить, що я новачок, і вирішує допомогти.
- Ось, візьміть, зробіть цінники.
- Звичайно.
- Щоб люди не думали, що ви просто перехожий.
- Точно!
- Бо в американських доларах ви ж не хочете.
Я з'ясував, що моя сусідка до того, як піти на пенсію,
працювала у посольствах Німеччини у країнах Південно-Східної Азії.
У фрау Кімме старий одяг розходиться, як гарячі пиріжки:
відчувається дипломатичний досвід. Вона і мені ледь не продала плащ.
І дала чимало порад.
– Ви маєте робити рекламу. Коли бачите, що хтось зацікавився, одразу кажіть:
подивіться, все в ідеальному стані, все працює.
Бо інакше люди ітимуть далі і казатимуть…. ну не знаю…
Після першого мого успіху - кількагодинна пауза.
Люди підходять, цікавляться велосипедом, але не
Фрау Кімме пропонує змінити стратегію.
Вона пише на ціннику дві літери: "фау" і "бе".
- Ферхандлюнгсбазіс. Це означає, що можна торгуватися щодо ціни.
- Постійно треба вчитись у досвідчених!
Змінюю стратегію: переходжу до агресивного маркетингу.
- Підходимо, берем – найкращі, найдешевші велосипеди!
- Михайло, ти в Німеччині!
- Ха-ха, точно!
- (нім.) Купуйте найкращий велосипед на блошиному ринку!
Через п'ять годин від першого продажу доля посміхнулася мені вдруге :
я поступаюсь у ціні і пропоную і велосипед, і причіп разом купити за сто євро.
Пані погоджується.
- Я справді рада. Це дуже гарний велосипед.
- Щиро дякую!
- Нема за що дякувати, я б вам 120 євро заплатила.
- Так, звичайно!
Філософія ресайклінгу  у дії.
Потриманий, але міцний «Геркулес» продовжить своє життя у нових руках.
Друзі, пишіть у коментарях, що вас ще цікавить у Німеччині,
і я розповім про це у наступних серіях. Побачимось!